Good afternoon.
Welcome to the Meet the Expert session with
Maria Blasco: Targeting Telomeres in Cancer and Aging.
As you may know, Maria is
one of the leaders in telomere biology, and she's going
to be telling us about her latest research. Thank you so much.
And you can pose your questions.
You can either use the QR code to enter your questions online,
but also you can, after the talk, ask your questions in
the microphone. Thank you.
Hi, good afternoon. So it's a pleasure for me to tell you
about the work we are doing on the role of telomeres in cancer and aging.
So I will start telling you about the role of telomeres in aging,
because as you know, aging is the highest risk factor also for cancer.
And then I will tell you about the work we are doing with trying to target
telomeres in cancer. So as you know, aging is
the cause of many of the diseases that kill us.
Among these diseases are diseases like cancer,
or I highlighted fibrosis because I will be telling
about the role of telomeres in fibrosis, and fibrosis is also a
risk factor for cancer,
like in the case of liver, lung fibrosis.
So
we think that the causes of aging have the key to
understand all of these diseases.
They can be influenced by the genes, but also by the habits.
And understanding these causes of aging will allow us to have biomarkers
for early detection of these diseases, but
also we will be able maybe to prevent the appearance of these
diseases by delaying aging, and also to have
better and more effective treatments for the diseases associated with aging, and I
include here also cancer. So which are these causes
of aging?
So,
there are several very well-characterized molecular pathways that have been
demonstrated to be important for aging, and one of them is the telomere
shortening.
Telomere shortening associated to cell division due to the end replication problem.
And
telomere shortening, in turn, has been
defined as a primary cause of aging because it leads to other causes of aging,
like genomic instability, for instance, which is also underlying cancer
risk, stem cell exhaustion, et cetera.
Recently, we have updated this review by including other hallmarks
of aging. But again, telomere shortening is one of the primary causes
of aging.
Telomeres, however, have to be maintained somehow,
because if not, it would be impossible to maintain the species, or it would be
impossible for cancer cells to divide.
And in fact, there is an activity called telomerase that is able to re-elongate
telomeres. So telomerase is able to elongate telomeres, and this is what
allows the maintenance of different generations in the species.
When we are born, telomerase is silenced, and this leads to telomere shortening.
Telomere shortening has been demonstrated to lead to age-related
diseases. And there is the case of the so-called telomere
biology diseases. These are people that have mutations in telomerase, and they are
going to develop prematurely a number of diseases, including,
as I said before, different types of fibrosis.
Cancer is also a disease associated to short telomeres,
which lead to chromosomal instability.
But in the case of cancer cells, they escape this mortality
produced by short telomeres by activating telomerase,
which is one of the most mutated genes in cancer, actually.
And telomere length has been proposed to be a biomarker for this
aging of our cells and tissues.
So we know that
if you induce telomere shortening, this is sufficient to induce aging.
But my lab also demonstrated that if you make mice with
longer telomeres, and in this case, we did it by
overexpressing the telomerase catalytic subunit, the
TERT gene,
they can live more and have also less cancer.
So,
having longer telomeres in mice, at least,
we show here that it protected from cancer.
More recently, we have shown the same by using a telomerase
activation strategy, a telomerase gene therapy.
We show that if we treated mice with telomerase, this delay many
diseases of aging, including cancer.
So again, showing that maintaining telomeres
was protecting from cancer. And in fact, we didn't see
any deleterious effects of activating telomerase in this
experiment because, in fact, the mice lived longer,
both the
group that was treated at the middle age, one year old, and a group
treated at an old age, two years old.
This would open the question, why don't we have longer telomeres then if
long telomeres are not
apparently bad? So we try to address this question
by doing an epigenetic trick in mice
again. We know that telomerase is activated in the inner cell mass,
and we also know that ES cells and iPS cells, they have high
levels of telomerase. My group
show, discovered by chance, that if you maintain pluripotent
cells in vitro, dividing, telomeres keep growing
beyond the natural length of the inner cell mass of the
species. And in this way, we generated ES cells that we call
with ultra-long telomeres, much longer telomeres than normal.
And we have used this
trick to generate chimeric mice that
are born with much longer telomeres than normal without altering the
telomerase gene or any other gene.So you can see here what we
did was we took a cell modular, we aggregated ES cells with
ultra long or normal telomeres. In this case, you can see the ultra
long telomeres. We are going to see them in green
color, expressing the GFP. And then we generated chimeric mice.
So this is the eye of one of these chimeric mice, and you can
see the telomeres in red color, and you can see areas of the eye which much
longer telomeres than natural. So these mice have very long telomeres,
double the length of a normal mouse.
The question is, are they going to have more cancer, less cancer, live longer?
And we see that they live longer. So, this we expect because telomeres
start off with a longer length, even though the
telomere shortening is the same as in normal mice, and they are also cancer
protected. Even when we induce chemical carcinogenesis in these
mice, they have less cancer. We have also done this with
100% chimeras, so all the cells of the mouse
have ultra long telomeres, and they are also cancer protected.
So
long telomeres or longer telomeres than normal in a mouse at least are
not leading to more cancer. They are delaying
aging and also delaying cancer.
So what we have been doing regarding the role of telomeres in aging is to try
to use this telomerase gene therapy to show whether it's
effective for the treatment
of different age-related diseases, as well as these telomere biology
syndromes. So we have shown that telomerase gene
therapy has a therapeutic effect in cardiovascular
disease, in particular in heart infarct.
We have also shown therapeutic effects in mouse models of aplastic anemia
associated to short telomeres and pulmonary
and kidney fibrosis. I will be showing you that because, as I said,
fibrosis, I think, is also very interesting for cancer because it's also at the
origin of cancer.
So
these telomere biology diseases, many of them are characterized by this
fibrosis, which is also a risk factor for cancer.
And our model, in the case of pulmonary fibrosis, was
the first telomere biology disease to be shown to be
associated to dysfunctional telomeres, is that these short
telomeres probably
synergize with damaging agents to the lung, like smoking
or pollution. And
when the telomeres are short, the regenerative compartment of the
lung cannot regenerate. We have shown that short telomeres impede
stem cell mobilization, and when you don't have regeneration, you have immune
response and fibrosis. And the current treatments
actually are not curing the patients.
They are tackling fibrosis, but they are not
curative, and we think it's because you still have the cause there.
In the case of at least a third of the
cases of pulmonary fibrosis are suspected to be associated to
short telomeres.
This is in addition to the familial cases.
And if you have short telomeres, it impedes regeneration.
So we first try to identify which is the cell type
of origin of fibrosis associated to short telomeres.
And for that, what we did in collaboration with AstraZeneca in the
US, we induced telomere dysfunction in different cell types
of the lung
by deleting one of the telomere binding proteins.
And we saw that only when we induced telomere dysfunction in the
alveolar type two cells, so the cell types that we studied,
we have
interstitial fibrosis similar to the human disease.
But this does not happen when we induce telomere dysfunction in fibroblasts
or in the basal cells or in the club cells.
So this is pointing to these 82 cells are the cells we would
want to target in order to treat pulmonary fibrosis associated with
short telomeres.
In mouse models, we have shown that
this telomerase gene therapy can target these 82
cells, and we can
slow down or reverse fibrosis induced by
short telomeres.
And
at the molecular level, we see that we isolate the 82
cells of these mice. They express telomerase, and
they rescue DNA damage and immune signaling pathways.
And this is why we have this therapeutic effect
in the lung fibrosis model. It's a lung fibrosis model induced
by short telomeres and a low dose of bleomycin that does
not induce fibrosis in a wild-type mouse.
So
short telomeres are in the origin of the disease in this mouse model.
It's like a humanized mouse model of pulmonary fibrosis.
So the question is: Well, maybe we can cure fibrosis, but
are we going to induce cancer because I told you before that cancer
cells need to activate telomerase in order to divide indefinitely.
And we did this safety experiment in which at the same time or
before we put telomerase, we
activated an oncogene, K-RAS, in the lung to see whether
telomerase was influencing the natural history of the
K-RAS induced tumors
in this mouse model developed by the group of Mariano Barbacid at
the CNIO.
And you can see that the telomerase
in the pre-treatment or simultaneous treatment models did not
increase the number of mice with tumors, the tumors per
mouse, or the tumor
size. So telomerase was not actually changing
the tumors induced by K-RAS in this model.
Of course,
humans are different, but at least in a mouse model where we are forcing lung
cancer by inducing K-RAS mutation,
telomerase is not altering theLet's say the number of
tumors or the size of tumors indicating on the safety of the--
I forgot to tell you, I will remind you that in the experiment I showed you
before, where we treat mice with telomerase gene therapy, and we wait
until all the mice die. Actually, cancer was delayed, and the mice lived
longer. So again, showing that this strategy,
with non-integrative, associated viruses, is not
leading to more cancer, the expression of telomerase.
So basically, we have shown that telomerase gene therapy can elongate
lifespan in mice, slow down the progression of lung fibrosis, and
we did not see more cancer in the lung when we forced the expression of
K-RAS mutations in the lung. And we
have now developed the
human vectors, and
I want to disclose that there is a company funded, which is called Telomere
Therapeutics, that is trying to
bring this to humans.
So one important thing is to understand the role of
the different mutations that are defined in the human patients.
And I want to discuss one of the latest mutations found in patients of
pulmonary fibrosis, which is in a telomere binding protein called POT1.
I think POT1 is interesting because it's found mutated both in
cancer and aging.
So the same protein, which is a telomere binding protein important for telomerase
activity at the telomeres, is found mutated in familial cases
of cancer and familial cases of pulmonary fibrosis, which
is an age-related disease.
So in the case of the pulmonary fibrosis, we generated a mouse model,
which is recapitulating this mutation,
the human mutation in mice, and we see that the mutation leads to short
telomeres,
telomere fragility, which we measure by what we call the
multi-telomeric signals. And
we see that this mutation
phenocopies the telomerase knockout model.
So with increasing generations of this mutation, we get shorter and shorter
telomeres.
And actually, we compare
the phenotype. So the telomerase knockout with the POT1
mutant that we are studying here,
you can see that they are identical. We look at, for instance, at the litter size.
There is a decrease in the litter size, which is the same in the telomerase
knockout, increasing generation of the telomerase knockout or increasing
generations of the POT1
knock-in mouse model.
Even the pathologies that we found in the telomerase knockout,
which are characterized by
small intestinal atrophy
or testicular atrophy. You can see that
in the third generation, POT1 knock-in and the third
generation telomerase knockout, they are equivalent.
So
this mutation is acting like--
I don't have time to show you, but
if we overexpress telomerase in this POT1, it's not rescued in the short
telomerase, so this mutation is acting as a dominant negative for telomerase.
So,
you can have a mutation in this telomere binding protein that is impeding the
action of telomerase on the telomere, and that's why it's causing fibrosis.
You will see that other mutations do exactly the opposite, and they are found in
familiar cases of cancer.
So another disease we have been studying is renal fibrosis, which
is also very prevalent. And I don't have time to tell you the
details, but my group has shown that short telomeres also lead
to or are the origin of kidney fibrosis in mouse models.
And in this particular case, we also discovered something unexpected, which
is that short telomeres were sufficient to induce mesenchymal
drift. So we found an epithelial to mesenchymal transition, which
has been shown before to lead to kidney fibrosis, to be induced
by short telomeres. And I think this is also very interesting
because this mesenchymal transition is common to cancer and aging,
and short telomeres can
induce that. So it could be also the origin of this common aspect of cancer and
aging,
which is called mesenchymal drift.
So the same as we did with the lung, we have identified the cell of origin of
kidney fibrosis associated to dysfunctional telomeres, and it's not
in the fibroblast or the pericytes.
Only
in very old mice we see some fibrosis when you induce telomere
dysfunction in the fibroblast or the pericytes.
However, when we induce telomere dysfunction in the renal tubular epithelial
cells or the basal cells, again, the more regenerative compartments, the
same as with the lung, we get fibrosis, a very severe
fibrosis. So again, it's the short telomeres in the epithelial compartments or
the basal compartments, the ones that are causing the fibrosis.
And I think this is interesting because even though fibrosis is characterized
by,
let's say, activation of fibroblasts,
it's when we induce telomere dysfunction in epithelial cells, when we get
this fibrotic phenotype.
And this is the part I wanted to tell you about
aging, and I will now switch to
cancer.
You know this very famous review by Juan Berrahan-Hanahan, and one
of the hallmarks of cancer is the ability of cancer cells to
divide indefinitely. And as I mentioned before, they achieve this
in 90% of the cases, more or less, by mutating
telomerase. So telomerase activity is reactivated in tumors
through mutations in promoters, amplification, et cetera, but not
only telomerase. My group also was
among the first groups that described mutations in shelterin,
in familiar cases of cancer,
and in particular, the first telomere binding protein found
mutated, and I think is one of the few actually found mutated in cancer, is
POT1. Again, the same one I told you before with pulmonary
fibrosis. So we found that POT1 mutation,
in this case, in the cancer caseleads to
abnormally long telomeres. So the opposite to the mutation I told
you for pulmonary fibrosis.
And these abnormally long telomeres, however, are not normal.
They are mutant for POT1, and this means that
they are more fragile, I will show you.
So these are long telomeres, it's true, but not normal long telomeres like the
ones I showed you before with the chimeric mice.
So we were the first one to describe these mutations in CLL, but then other groups
have described this mutation in glioblastoma and other tumor types,
other POT1 mutations. And we also found
a POT1 mutation in Li-Fraumeni like syndrome,
which is not associated to P53 mutations.
So this is a Li-Fraumeni syndrome with many different tumors
appearing in these families, including cardiac
tumors, which are very rare.
And
later on, the group of Mery Armanios also found a POT1
mutation in the cases of familial clonal hematopoiesis.
And so confirming our results
and showing that these abnormally long telomeres,
associated POT1 mutations
could be related to
morigenic processes. But I want to make the emphasis is that
a POT1 mutant telomere is not a normal telomere because it has
mutations in POT1.
So, this is some of the major tumor types where the mutations have
been found, and we generated a mouse model also for this Li-Fraumeni like
syndrome that we,
together with a group of Manuel Benito, discovered at the Spanish National
Cancer Center. And in this case, it's the opposite to the
POT mutant I showed you before for pulmonary fibrosis, we get longer
telomeres. In the case of the POT1 mutant, you can
see this in the
mutants compared to the wild types.
The telomeres are longer, and they are also more
fragile. And this is in MEFs and iPS, but
also in different tissues. And the mice also develop
angiosarcomas,
similar to the
human Li-Fraumeni like syndrome.
And in this case,
the mutant is not acting as a dominant negative as the one I showed you before,
for the POT1 mutation in pulmonary fibrosis, but is acting as a
processivity, let's say, increasing the processivity of telomerase.
So what happens with this mutant is allowing for a lower inhibition
of telomerase at the telomeres and a higher activity of telomerase at the
telomeres. The opposite to the other mutant that is acting as a dominant
negative.
So I think it's important to study every different mutation because it can lead
to very different phenotypes,
even if it's in the same protein.
So we have this ability of cancer cells to
maintain telomeres. This is
a hallmark of cancer, and
telomerase inhibitors have been
developed in the past. However, they have not been very successful, in part
because there is a phenotypic lag.
So a time
between when you inhibit telomerase and achieving short telomeres, which
probably is too long for some cancers.
And also because some tumors can maintain telomeres by recombination.
So inhibition of telomerase may not be that effective.
So our idea was, instead of targeting telomerase, to
target the telomere binding proteins, the sheltering proteins, which are the
protective complex of the telomeres.
And, the group of Tite de Langa, but also our group, have shown
that all these proteins are essential for
cell division except POT1. And in particular, we were
interested in TRF1.
When you delete TRF1 in the mice, you induce telomere dysfunction in
every single chromosome end. So it's a
persistent telomere damage, which is sufficient to stop cells.
But TRF1,
compared to the other shelterins, has another property that is important for
stem cells, and my group has been doing work on that.
It's overexpressed in pluripotent and adult stem cell
compartments, and is essential to maintain pluripotency and stemness
in adult cells. So we thought it could be a good target for a potential
therapy targeting telomeres in cancer.
And using mouse models, we have shown that this is effective,
of course, in mouse models of lung cancer and also
glioblastoma. We have shown the
benefit of inhibiting TRF1 in these two cancer
models.
And we have seen that this is not
too toxic. So if we
delete TRF1 in the whole organism,
in a wild type or P53 or P16 ARF
mutant backgrounds, this is not changing dramatically the
survival of the mice. So we of course get some phenotypes
in the skin and the hair.
But
still,
inhibition of TRF1 in the embryo is lethal, but in
the adult, it's allowing for a therapeutic window, as you can see
here. And we don't get more tumors in the case of the P16
ARF or the P53 mutants, which was something that worried
us. Maybe we inhibit TRF1 and we can stop
cancer growth. But down the line, TRF1 is going to lead to chromosomal instability
and secondary tumors. But this, in mouse models at least, doesn't seem to be the
case. So this led us to
start the screenings for small molecules that will be able to target
telomeres. And we develop a knock-in
mouse, where TRF1 is fused to
GFP, and you have the telomeres green, and you can look for inhibitors
that decrease the green fluorescence, which is the telomere binding
protein TRF1.
And we found-- Sorry.We
found
several molecules. We target deconvolute them, and we found
something that we didn't know before, is that the
PI3K/Akt pathway is
important for TRF1 stability. So when you have
inhibitors with PI3K/Akt, you
decrease the amount of TRF1 at telomeres, and that's why these inhibitors are
inhibiting TRF1. Then we found that TRF1 is phosphorylated, but
by Akt.
This is in the mouse, if you mutate this
residue that is phosphorylated by Akt, you decrease TRF1
phosphorylation. And this is important
in vivo because it decreases TRF1 stability,
decreases the binding to telomeric oligos,
and when you try to reconstitute a telomerase-deficient cell with these
mutants, they also fail to locate to the telomere.
So this phosphorylation of TRF1 by Akt is important for TRF1 stability.
This is in the mouse, but we found that human TRF1 is also phosphorylated by
Akt,
and if we generate a mutant in the phosphorylation site
using this knock-in, using CRISPR-Cas in human
cells, we see a
decrease TRF1 levels,
more DNA damage, and we also see
decreased telomere length in the case of the human cells.
So again, in TRF1 phosphorylation in human
cells by Akt is important for TRF1 stability
and for telomere length. Because we use a cancer cell line to do the
knock-ins, we check also the ability of this cancer cell line
to induce tumors. And you can see that the TRF1
mutants that cannot be phosphorylated by Akt have
a slower growth of tumor. So,
this was very interesting for us because all this is telling us that in human and
mouse cells,
telomeres can be modified by the environment.
So in this case, by the
PI3K/Akt pathway. So
the status of telomere protection can be altered by
these pathways that respond to the
environment. So I think this is very interesting.
And actually what we did next is to screen for
different FDA-approved drugs
to see how many of them were targeting TRF1.
If the telomere protection is important for cancer, and
we are finding signaling pathways that regulate TRF1, maybe we will
find other pathways that are important for telomere protection.
And actually, we found that the PI3K/Akt pathway,
but we also found the RAS pathway as an important pathway,
regulating TRF1
post-transcriptional regulation.
And actually, you can see here the different phosphorylation sites that we have
found in TRF1.
And there is one particular site,
threonine 330, that is phosphorylated by
many different kinases,
including the RAS, the mTOR, and the Akt pathway.
So what we have done is to
generate both phospho-mimetic and
phospho-dead mutants in this site in mice to see the in
vivo function of this mutation. So this is still unpublished, but we have
generated mice knock-in for this particular site,
which is phospho-dead or phospho-mimetic.
And we see that the
phospho-dead
has a
tendency to have lower TRF1.
The phospho-mimetic has higher levels of TRF1, and this is
correlated to a stability, to a half-life of TRF1.
So the phospho-dead, as we saw in the case of the human
cancer cells or in the case of the mouse
cells,
in vitro,
there is less stability for TRF1, and the phospho-mimetic has a higher stability.
We have seen also that the phospho-dead has shorter telomeres.
In the mouse, these are MEFs.
And this correlates with a higher presence of
undetectable telomeres or signal-free ends, and the phospho-mimetic
has,
in this case, in
the MEFs, there is normal telomeres or a tendency to have
longer telomeres. And this is dependent on telomerase, because when we have the
double mutants,
these
longer telomeres are here. You cannot appreciate, but you will see that the
telomeres of the phospho-mimetic are longer.
So one very nice assay to check the importance of
something for telomere elongation is reprogramming.
Because during reprogramming, we have shown that telomeres are massively elongated.
You can do this in vitro, and you see this.
You see that the telomeres are elongated when you reprogram.
So we can show that the phospho-dead
cannot elongate telomeres. So this mutant,
which cannot be phosphorylated in this site,
is like having a telomerase knockout,
no telomere elongation at all, the same as with
the telomerase knockout.
And the phospho-mimetic, however, you can elongate
telomeres.
So this is telling us that in vivo, this
post-transcriptional modification of TRF1 can have a huge effect, like
not getting the telomeres elongated by
telomerase.So again,
but then something which is very mysterious that we are trying still to understand,
and this is still unpublished and new data, the phospho
dead, you have shorter telomeres, but then
you have a normal decrease in telomere length.
But the phosphomimetic, which have much longer telomeres at
birth, then the telomeres are degraded very rapidly.
So
I will tell you, which is my hypothesis, but this is something interesting.
You can see this in MEFs. The phosphomimetic starts
off with much longer telomeres, but the telomeres are degraded very
rapidly. So as a consequence of this
mutation. When you look at survival and cancer, we see that the
phospho dead has a lower survival, a
normal or a tendency to lower survival.
And the
phospho dead, however, is living longer, which is
something surprising because I told you that this
is like having a telomerase knockout because the telomeres are not elongated.
And also they have a tendency to have more cancer.
We have done also chemical carcinogenesis, and you can see that they have more
papillomas when we
treat these mice with chemical carcinogens.
So
the
way we have to explain this is that, for some reason, the phospho
dead
seems to have a higher
stemness. And we can see this by reprogramming.
You can see that the phospho dead has a higher frequency
of reprogramming, even though the telomeres are not elongated.
However, the phosphomimetic, which
can elongate telomeres by telomerase,
reprograms much worse. And
this could be, in part, the explanation
for the different survival. So
the
phenotypes are opposite of the phospho dead and the phosphomimetic,
and
we think that probably what is going on with the phosphomimetic is
that as long as there is telomerase, the telomeres are
maintained. But in the adult mouse, that there is no telomerase, the telomeres are
degraded much faster. So probably this mutation is
important to prevent--
is allowing for a higher telomere degradation.
So we are still trying to understand this, but I want to put this as an
example of how
mutations in a residue that
this was related by many
different kinases are having such strong phenotypes in mind.
So pointing to the importance of telomere regulation by
extracellular factors,
which is something that we don't
understand at all. So I will finish here
with the
people from my lab. I want to particularly highlight Paula Martinez
and Giuseppe Gosso, that have done most of the work in the
cancer studies that I have shown you, which is the more recent work,
as well as Raul Mendez. And to thank also the drug
discovery at the CNIO,
which is called Experimental Therapeutics Program, and this is the funding of my
lab through these years. And I think I finish here.
I have 60 minutes for questions,
so I will stop here.
I hope there are some questions.
This was an amazing talk.
Thank you.
So I actually have a couple of questions.
The first one is, when you do the gene therapy with telomerase,
is it integrated in the genome, or is it just transient
overexpression of telomerase?
Yeah, these are adeno-associated viruses.
They
are non-integrative, even though there could be some integration, but it's very,
very low. So it's a transient expression of telomerase.
So as cells divide, they dilute out telomerase, and we think that this is in part
why
it's a safe strategy, because if any cell
hyper proliferates, it will dilute out telomerase.
It will lose the advantage of having telomerase.
Okay.
And
is it possible that the TRF1 could have other functions other
than regulating telomere length?
Yeah, very
good question. And it yes, it's true.
We have shown that
TRF1 is a target of AUKEF4 and is
upregulated very early during reprogramming and is essential for reprogramming.
And we have also shown that it's important for adult stem cells.
We
are still trying to understand
how is TRF1 essential for pluripotent and
adult stem cells. We don't fully understand that.
So we are trying to find, for instance,
which pathways could rescue, because if you
delete TRF1, you block completely pluripotency, or you
kill completely the
iPS cells. So we're trying to look for pathways that rescue this to try to
understand how is
TRF1 important for pluripotency. We don't know yet.
Okay.
But other shelterins don't seem to have the same
role.
Okay.
Very interesting data. Thank you.
Thank you.
So my question is,
you've shown two examples of the sheltering complex
proteins, POT1 and TRF1. In the case
of POT1, there is cancer mutations.
But
what else is known about dysregulation of these
proteins in cancer?
Mm.
What is known about maybe them being overexpressed?
Yeah.
What is known about, for example, their epigenetic regulation?
Are they epigenetically silenced, et cetera?
This is a very interesting point also.
There is quite a lot of data of overexpression, and
we have ourselves confirmed TRF1
overexpression, for instance, in glioblastoma.
That was also something important for us in order to show that TRF1 could be a good
target in the case of glioblastoma when we started
this project of trying to inhibit TRF1 in cancer
and in other tumor types. But I
don't know there is
such a thorough analysis of--
probably this can be done, looking at the cancer genome
data.
But the one I can mention is TRF1 that is
overexpressed in different cancers.
And then a second question, you mentioned that, I think it was with
POT1, that the resulting telomeres are distinct.
So are they
different in stability, in sequence-
Mm-hmm
... fidelity?
Oh.
What is different about them, and how do you explain it?
Yeah. We find them more fragile.
Telomere fragility can be detected by
using a telomeric FISH.
Instead of having the four telomeres at the end of the metaphase
chromosomes, you have what we have called multi-telomeric
signals. So you see several telomeric signals at the end of the chromosomes,
and this has been shown by the group of Titia de Lange, by my group, to be the
result of telomere replication problems
or telomere fragility. So the POT mutants that
we have analyzed that are mutated in cancer, in CLL, at least, and Li-Fraumeni like
syndrome,
which is not associated to P53 mutations, they lead to this
telomere fragility. So the telomeres are not replicated
properly when there are these mutations found in cancer.
And this is different from these
mice with the long telomeres, which are
not mutated for POT1, but they have less cancer.
So I think it's not a matter of how long the telomeres are, but
whether these telomeres are the result of a mutation in POT1
in the case of cancer or of familial cancer cases.
Thank you.
Hi.
Very nice talk and-
Thank you
... a great overview on the field. I have a very basic question, and
that's related to what you showed at the beginning.
It looks that
somehow mice with
longer telomeres had quite a lot of benefits.
They lived longer, were more healthy.
And
I'm just wondering why in evolution, this has not
been
an important factor, thinking also in the fact that mice have, per definition,
longer telomeres than humans, when I remember right.
And isn't that a little bit counterintuitive?
Because humans live longer.
Can you explain that?
Yeah, very interesting questions.
The first one, maybe I can start with the answer to the second one.
Mice are born with longer telomeres, but
we and others have shown that,
in particular, I think my group has looked in many different species of,
we published this in 2019, different species of
mammals and birds, which are very distant in evolution.
We have measured the telomere length at birth and the rate of telomere
shortening. Telomere length at birth does not correlate with longevity, but
the rate of telomere shortening,
it can predict longevity. So actually can be adjusted to
a mathematical function that is called a power law that will predict
longevity, and this has been reproduced by other authors.
So
not the total telomere length
of a species is related to longevity, but the rate of telomere
shortening, so how well
we are able to maintain the telomeres.
And why mice don't have longer telomeres?
This is a very interesting question.
I would say that mice have enough telomeres to live
two years and a half, and usually in nature, a mouse doesn't live more than
three, six months.
So they have plenty of telomeres to
live a useful life in nature. The same can
be said about us. So our life expectancy
was much lower than now, and probably we have
more than enough telomeres to survive the time we used to survive in
nature,
before
civilization and all that. So probably, we have to
see this as how long did the species or
do the species survive in nature. And I would say that
they have plenty of telomeres.
In nature, there is no aging.
No, I see that. Thanks. And just a follow-up question.
What determines at the end,
the speed of telomere
loss? Because it cannot be just replication.
No.
Yeah.
No. I think the most
likely
answer to that is DNA repair
efficiency, and this correlate with the works that are being published
by
different authors about the rates of DNA repair and
longevity. Telomeres are DNA, and
depending on how efficient
a species is repairing damage,
probably this
has to be demonstrated. We have not demonstrated it.
It's just a hypothesis
that it could be the DNA repair.
Okay. Thank you.
Very nice work and very nice talk. Thank you.
So I have a question that in the human cancer, they
often see the dysfunction in telomere, but yet have
reactivation of telomerase.
We know that you talk about that when you have the
activated telomerase, you can prevent all-
Yep
... the cancer. But in the human cancer, with
this kind of phenotype, they already have a dysfunctional
telomere. What do you suggest how to target in this
cancer?
I think there are different aspects of the role of telomerase in cancer.
On one hand, we know that dysfunctional telomeres, short telomeres, lead to more
cancer risk because of the persistent DNA damage and
chromosomal
instability that they generate.
But once you have
a cancer, and for that, you don't need telomerase.
Actually, I think
we show that even though in the initial experiments of the
transformation of human cells, they put telomerase,
Weinberg, et cetera. Then, actually together with Greg
Hannon, that he passed away unfortunately recently, we showed
after that you can transform
cells without telomerase. So cells can be transformed without telomerase,
and then if you want to maintain these cells, probably you need to activate
telomerase. But telomerase is not important for transformation of cells
to go from a normal cell to a cancer cell.
Telomerase necessary then to maintain the telomeres, right?
Because if not, there's nothing that can grow if it doesn't maintain the
telomeres. But telomerase is not necessary for transformation.
Yeah, but with those,
we already have the telomere dysfunction, like with the ALT,
alternative,
for the telomere.
Yeah.
What kind of-
In cancer, I would say that once you have a tumor and this tumor is maintaining
telomeres, you want to destroy the telomeres, right?
And that's why we
have been aiming to target these telomere binding proteins, because we think they
are better targets than telomerase.
Thank you.
Excellent talk.
Thank you so much.
I have a question regarding
POT1 mutations leading to extremely long telomeres
and predisposition to cancer. My understanding is they just do not
undergo senescence, they proliferate, proliferate, proliferate.
Do they select, in terms of carcinogenesis,
for certain clonal growth due to certain somatic
oncogenic mutations then, due to this proliferation?
Because you mentioned that PI3K/AKT, BRAF, I think there
was BRAF also-
Yeah. Actually-
... you mentioned that
... we are-
Yeah
... studying that. It's still unpublished, but yeah, BRAF. Important.
Maintained then this TRF1
system. Is
something like this kind of mechanism engaged in
carcinogenesis?
Yeah, this is very interesting. There
are the familial cases, of course.
Yeah.
But then also
the somatic, the
sporadic cases, probably are something very interesting
to study. I don't know the answer. I think this is something that would
be very interesting to study. What is clear is that in
the familial case, there are familial cases of cancer
associated to these mutations in
POT1, mainly POT1.
And have you
seen, because I saw some sarcomas, have you seen
for example, thyroid cancer or other BRAF mutants
that on the basis of this
germline background of POT1 would develop as familial?
Yeah, I think this is an interesting question. I don't know the answer.
Maybe this is something that is being studied, but it would be interesting to
study. Yeah, it's important. And going to your
question, certainly,
I don't know about POT1 because we have not studied that.
I don't think it has been studied at all.
But in the case of TRF1, the RAS pathway is regulating
TRF1.
Right.
Thank you. Very interesting. Thank you so much.
Thank you.
I don't see online questions, I think.
There are no questions, so I think if we don't have more
questions, I think we
are done. Thank you very much for coming.
Thank
you.